what makes a great story what makes a
great story I think ultimately if it
evokes an emotional response whatever
that emotion is whether it be elation
sadness fear if it evokes an emotion
it's a great story how that happens is
so many things and so many things but it
has to evoke something because it's not
the proof that people leave feeling like
okay that was smart like you know like
it could be brilliant but did they feel
anything from it so I think if it folks
an emotion through the story not just a
random you know through the story of
voguing emotion it's a good story
have you watched a film where you could
tell other people weren't into it but
you were or vice versa it was one that
was recommended the critics all loved it
and you're like yeah I just it didn't
get to me right here yeah it normally
happens the other way around where I'm
like this was awesome and people are
like I didn't get anything from and I'm
like what but yeah sometimes where you
hear all this these things about a movie
people love it and I'm like this is all
right usually it's something that's very
niche so in this day and age where
things can go viral like that's like
it's just boom everyone loves it but
it's usually a core group of people
loved it and they spread it they were so
excited about it because it felt it fit
a certain niche that they're in and then
other people will follow because people
were cheap the masses follow the masses
and they're like oh it's great and then
it's great it's great it's great it's
great and it gets to be this huge thing
and then someone coming into it they're
like it's okay
but it's it wasn't their niche and most
of the people are watching and saying
it's great it's probably not their niche
there's cut they're grabbing on to the
truth that someone else told them and
they're going into it with expectations
and bringing their own like someone
else's excitement into the into the room
so I found that usually when a story
doesn't necessarily connect with me or
Wow me and some people are really
excited it's a personal thing like maybe
I know this one movie I watched and I
cried on it like I don't cry a lot of
movies but I cried and I was like
reading reviews and they're like it was
disconnected it didn't talk to the
audience I you know it was just bashing
the connection part which I'm like I
cried but I realized I had a personal
thing that connected with them
so for me it was a great movie so that's
all we need to do as writers producers
filmmakers we only need to connect with
the audience and we need to connect in a
while a wide enough space for people to
love it and then we have a story we have
a movie what takes you out of a film
what ruins a story for you
um for me it's tough when I feel like a
lack of authenticity in a project core
or film or script that can take me out
of it I can just just kind of just okay
because they they maybe said something
the actor says something the character
is speaking and I know I just met the
character for like a whole 30 minutes
that doesn't fit what they're doing that
doesn't fit where they're saying so I
felt like they tried to push a narrative
or push something because it felt right
for or fun for the project but it's like
but you just introduce me to the
character be something different and if
a character steps out of themselves and
acts in a way that's completely off the
way they should actor the way they are
prone to act there should be something
that tells me that there's an
opportunity for that to happen so a man
that is so loving and kind then all of a
sudden is mean to his wife I'm like oh
my gosh what's happening rather than
like okay so I have to stay connected by
proof and truth so we stay outside
taking stories we if we come from a
place of truth and for a writer that's
knowing the I mean the the characters
that you're writing and know what they
would say for producer it's keeping an
eye on the full picture watching it and
making sure everything fits into that
from what the character is wearing all
these things you can't hire a wardrobe
designer that doesn't think about okay
this guy is a blue collar guy we need a
lot more wear and tear on his clothes
that could take me out the moment it's
like okay that guy's jacket is very
fresh I'm out and I don't blame that the
just the wardrobe designer in there I
blame the producer because if you see
these things you keep an eye on
everything and the upm and all these
people like you're tracking people you
should know that something is off here
and it should be adjusted industry
conversations about the director should
be talking to your creative team on a
regular basis and they do they all do to
where you understand that everything I'm
telling you about the story I know the
director you're gonna take the story and
then apply it to your niche so the
production design it shouldn't be bright
and colorful if we're about to go into a
like let's bring it down let's get some
real material in there and let's not
have a lot of you know brand-new type
materials let's get some wood in there
let's get some some metal and their
scene or whatever it is like I want
everyone to have that same vision and
then apply it so producer make sure your
director has a vision and make sure they
know how to convey it if they're not
conveying it step in and make sure you
you're intervening and making sure that
he's able to do it or she's able to do
that and then on the writer side the
same thing do you know your characters
you're pitching a story to me you want
me to get the finance tell me about the
characters oh well in the script they do
it no not what they do in the script
tell me about them like tell me about
their lives so then I'm when I'm reading
the script
red flag no you just told me that that
guy is like really narcissistic you told
me that when I met you and now I'm
reading this Kara moment why is he
having a caer moment you didn't prove it
well it's Kara because this is the
moment where he changes okay prove it
show me so that the audience doesn't
feel get disconnected so I think would
easily you can pull an audience out by
not remaining authentic in any capacity
writing production design wardrobe hair
makeup anything it all needs to be with
the director's vision in mind and that
director should have a very strong
vision that can be applied throughout
and that's the producers job to make
sure it happens
you